Jeffrey Feng: Hey, guys, how's it going.
Vincent: hey? Good to see you? This meeting is pretty informal. So let us just talk about our screen break first.
Yooni Choi: Yeah, tell us about it. You want to visit your girlfriend right?
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah. It was great. I went to North Carolina to visit her.
Jeffrey Feng: We went out and spent some time exploring good restaurants in Raleigh. It was really nice to see her again.
Vincent: Yeah, and that sounds amazing. I went to Georgia to see my girlfriend to, and I managed to spend some time working on my capsulum project
Vincent: as well as my advanced cloud computing homework.
Yooni Choi: And how did that go?
Vincent: It went pretty well. Actually, I was able to finish both projects, and I think I did a good job. It was nice to be able to focus on it without any distraction.
Jeffrey Feng: That's awesome, man. Congrats on finishing it.
Yooni Choi: And what about you, Jeffrey? Did you get anything done while that while you were there?
Jeffrey Feng: Honestly not really. This homework is too difficult, and I was not able to figure out the design of the spark workflow. But now that i'm back, I need to really focus on getting this project done.
Vincent: Yeah, I hear you this project car where for this week I can keep keep working on my capsule. There. I guess you're like Sh them is to go to the advanced Cloud computing office hours and ask the ta for help, and then my action item is to keep working on that capstone
Jeffrey Feng: sounds good to me.
Yooni Choi: Speaking of cloud projects, I actually did some homework, too. While I was in Cancun I was able to finish one of my assignments, but I still have a lot more to do
Jeffrey Feng: That's impressive. I wouldn't even think about doing any work if I were in.
Vincent: That's true. But no, that we are back. We can all focus on getting everything down
Yooni Choi: definitely. I will start my next cloud with Simon early, so I have more time to work on my other homework. My action item is to finish my spark assignment for the cloud assignment before Friday.
Jeffrey Feng: That's a good idea, and if you do the same thing
Vincent: same here, we can all hold each other accountable and make sure we stay on track
Yooni Choi: absolutely. It's important to make the most of our time and get everything done on time.
Jeffrey Feng: agreed. So what's next on our agenda? Is that it?
Jeffrey Feng: Oh, wait! We need to talk about what to do after the spring semester ends right.
Vincent: of course. What are your plans?
Jeffrey Feng: Well, I have a summer job line up, but it doesn't start until late, so i'll probably stay in Pittsburgh for a while and figure out what to do. In the meantime
Yooni Choi: i'm thinking of going back to Korea for a bit. My job starts in July, so if I have plenty of time between the end of my exams and the start of my job, I might as well make a trip back home.
Vincent: That sounds nice. I'm not sure what i'm going to do yet. I my visit my girlfriend again. But I really depends on how things go, because my job might not earlier.
Jeffrey Feng: That's understandable looking for Some of housing can also be tough.
Yooni Choi: Yeah, but i'm sure you'll plan it out soon, Dodger.
Vincent: Thanks.
Jeffrey Feng: So are we gonna keep in touch over the summer
Yooni Choi: definitely. We should make sure to catch up every once in a while and see how things are going.
Vincent: Agree? Let's catch up later.
Yooni Choi: All right. I'll talk to you guys later. Then bye
Vincent: bye.